now one of the most respected scientists
who was also spiritualists was this
gentleman here who's sort of doing some
exercise in his home sir Oliver Lodge he
very much
pursued both electromagnetic research
and study of spirits and telepathy as
two sides of the same coin
he's today famous for being one of the
pioneers of radio as well as inventing
the spark plug and the loud speaker so
he invented the device called the
coherer which was like a simple act
romantic wave detector and I spent much
of his later career sort of competing
with Marconi in commercializing at the
radio and he was also an active member
of the the SPR but he was very respected
he gave a lot of public lectures and he
was seen as this very very reliable
scientific figure so when Frederick
Myers that one of the founders of SPR
that we met earlier I decided to do an
experiment as is sort of I felt his end
of his life was approaching he gave a
lodge a sealed letter that was only to
be opened after after Mars his death and
he was going to try to pass on a message
from beyond that that was supposed to be
matched to the contents of the letter
and it seemed like the experiment was
successful so in 1901 a group of women
at the very highest level of British
society started receiving messages from
Meyers by automated writing and and at
least according to some interpretations
the messages matched the contents of the
letter that lodge had been given so so
one of the kind of key mediums where
some of the key mediums where Alice
Fleming up up on the left
he was the sister of sister of the
famous writer Rudyard Kipling and Alex
also co-authored some of Kipling's early
Indian tales as a side note Kipling also
wrote a great little short story called
the Wireless which is about contacting
the off light with radio another medium
receiving messages from from Myers was
Winifred Coombs tenants up there on the
right also a very remarkable woman a
suffragist Member of Parliament and
later the British delegate to the League
of Nations there were a few few others
others as well and they
although all the letters from Meijer
we're shared amongst this very elite
group and the hub of the group was the
sort of mist arts gentleman on the
bottom bottom left Arthur Balfour who
had been the president of the SPR and at
the time when these letters were
arriving he was the Prime Minister of
Britain and later he got the nickname
bloody Balfour for sort of cruelly
putting down unrest in Northern Ireland
and he was actually the one who signed
the declaration to found the state of
Palestine so a pretty important guy his
brother Gerald in the mayoral mill was
sort of equally accomplished and they
had a third brother Francis who died
very young at the age of thirty many
years before while climbing Mont Blanc
and he was known as for for his for his
talent in biology and people were saying
that he would be the successor to Darwin
but he died before he could realize that
in any case this group circulated all
these letters arriving from Frederick
Meyers from beyond from the afterlife
via automated writing and it was kind of
a shared hypertext if you like they kept
all this very secret and these letters
were all interconnected seemingly even
though different people received them
there were symbols that recurred from
classics from the Bible from Shakespeare
and so on and there were so many
interconnections that ultimately the
group became entirely convinced that
this was real as Meyers talking to them
from the afterlife other people started
talking to them from the afterlife
including James Littleton who'd been
sort of this lost love of arthur balfour
when he was young
died who had also died very young and
also frances ball for the brother had
the sort of third ball for brother and
there was a this big picture this this
plan or a story that started to emerge
from the letters and so so what myers
was was saying was that a kind of
Darwinian evolution continued in the
afterlife and and as Myers and and
Francis Beaufort had ended the off light
they had gotten a lot smarter and they
had been a sort of scientific revolution
in the afterlife people in the afterlife
had perfected the engineering of souls
and in fact Francis Balfour was leading
a team of spirit scientists who were
designing a perfect soul
a sort of perfectly engineered spirit
child whose task would be to deliver
humanity from chaos and and of course
this perfect soul only needed a vessel
to be incarnated into now again a bit of
context this was 1912 at this point and
the British elite had this kind of
widespread sense of crisis approaching
chaos in the world
there were socialists and anarchists and
feminists and suffragists and sort of
sort of unrest in Europe and all these
alliances unravelling so it was pretty
clear that somebody somebody needed to
to save the world so two members of this
group Sir Arthur's living brother
Gerald's in the middle and when a friend
up on the right so took one for the team
and they had an affair but there they
were they were instructed by by the
spirits to have an affair and whenever
it's much older husband actually knew
about it but but sort of maintained
stiff awful upper lip and and said
nothing about it and so Winifred got
pregnant and gave the birth gave birth
to the vessel of this perfect engineered
soul and I just can't help thinking how
remarkable this story is story is I mean
this is happening happening at the sort
of highest levels of British politics in
society combining all these these ideas
about eugenics and evolution and
engineering applied in this very
otherworldly context so here is the
spirit child at the age of one and then
at the age of thirty and I was called
Henry Kuhn tenant born in 1913 and as
far as we know he wasn't the Messiah he
didn't save the world from from chaos
unfortunately but he did have a pretty
interesting life
he studied in Cambridge he he met
Wittgenstein was taught by Ludwig
Wittgenstein the famous philosopher
fought in World War two and got
imprisoned escaped a German prison camp
by himself fled across Europe ended up
working for the British intelligence
service for mi6 together with kim Philby
he would later be revealed as one of the
most one of the deepest Soviet moles
double agents of all time and it was
really Henry's life that kind of made me
made me decide that
Summerland had to be had to be a spice
story and he was an inspiration for one
of the protagonists now later on Henry's
life sort of quieted down and but in the
50s he did try to contact his mother
Winifred through through through through
through a medium probably to complain
about about the kind of weird
circumstances of his birth or or to high
expectations and and and it's not clear
if he succeeded but soon after that he
did go away to become a Catholic monk
and lived for the rest of his life in
solitude so it is actually the kind of
biography you can never put in fiction
because nobody would nobody would
believe it
[Music]
you